وفي تفاصيل دراسه الامريكيه التي نشرت في
موقعي
اكدت النتائج ان اكثر من نصف الشركات
استبدلت بالفعل عدد من موظفيها لحل محلهم
الشركات التي استعنت بالمدردشه الذكي
الاصطناعيا اكدت انها وفرتنا بما يصل الى
50 الف دولار ووصل التوفير ببعضها لنحو
مئات الف دولار الشركات تستخدم في كتابه
الاعلانات وانشاء المحتوى ودعم العملاء
واعداد ملخصات الاجتماعات
77% من الشركات التي تستخدم تشاتشي تقول
انها تستخدمها للمساعده في كتابه توصفات
وظيفيه في مقال نحو 66% ان روبوت الدردشه
يقوم بالصياغه طلبات المقابلات فضلا عن
استخدامه بكتابه السيره الذاتيه والخطابات
التقديميه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من عمان خبير امن المعلومات
رايت سمور سيد رائد اهلا بك معنا بصباح
العربيه يسعد صباحك منورنا دائما يعني كما
سمعنا مئات شركات استبدلت موظفيها بشاتشي
هل اليوم الذكاء الاصطناعي يهدد الايدي
العامله ومئات الوظائف
صباح الخير
حقيقه لا انا لا اعتقد ذلك لا لا هذا
الكلام يعني
يجانب الصواب
الموضوع الموضوع كلياته انا تتبعت هذه
الدراسه الحقيقه وتتبعت المصدر الرئيسي
فيها وكانت هذه الدراسه يعني قامت عليها
شركه تجاريه شركه تقدم خدمات السيره
الذاتيه نماذج الجزيره ذاتيه فعمليا عملت
هي استطلاع لراي عام لا ادري مدى صحه هذا
الاستطلاع اكاديميا لانه من تقوم عليه
شركه غير محايده شركه تجاريه وبالتالي
خرجت في مثل هذه المسميات اولا المنصات
التشات جي بي تي ما زالت تحت التجربه وما
زالت في مراحلها
التجريبيه ولم نصل الى المنتج النهائي حتى
نقول ان في هناك شركات امريكيه قامت
باستخدام هذا التطبيق
وبالتالي تم استبدال العمالي لكن لكن
من حق الناس ان تتساءل ومن حق الناس ان
تتخوف لانه الحقيقه هذه التقنيه بالجانب
الكتابي بالجانب الابداعي الكتابي
صنع المحتوى خلق المحتوى انا اعتقد انه من
الممكن ان يؤثر لكن ان يؤثر مكان مثلا
نادين او مكان سهام في الاستوديو يمكن
يكون صعب اتفضل المكان بس بدي اقول لك
شغله
يعني
سكس بس بدي اقول لك شغله من يجب عليه ان
يشعر بالخطر وبالتهديد على نفسه وعلى
وظيفته غير نحن
من لا يطور نفسه تقنيا هذا يجب ان يشعر
بالخطاه من وجد نفسه بشهاده جامعيه معينه
بكفاءه معينه ولم يقم بتطوير ادواته الى
المفروض على اي موظف يريد ان يبقى في
وظيفته عليه ان يحسن ادائه عليه ان يحسن
من معلوماته وكفاءته باستخدام التقنيات
وخاصه
فعمليا من يقوم ومن يحسن الاستخدام في هذه
التقنيات انا سوف يبقى في عملي طيب غير
ذلك تستخدم الشركات تشارجي بي تي لانشاء
المحتوى لدعم العملاء اعداد ملخصات
الاجتماعات فما هي ابرز الوظائف التي قد
تكون مهدده في هذا الاطار لو تحدثنا عن
هذه الخبره لدى
يعني الوظائف المهدده هي وظائف السكرتاريه
وظائف المتابعه
الوظائف كتابه النصوص كتابه المحتوى نعم
هذه هذه
مهدده الان لكن على مستوى مثلا
مستوى الطيار مستوى
عسكري مستوى
مذيع محترف مذيعه محترفه انا لا اعتقد ذلك
يعني لا يعني لمعه العين عند المذيع لمعه
العين عند المذيعه عندما تواجه الكاميرا
بمحبه وحب هذا لا يمكن ان ياتي به اي
روبوت في الدنيا
فالوظائف الاداريه فقط هي من
هي الوظائف الاداريه من سوف يتاثر بهذا
الامر فقط وليس ليست الوظائف التقنيه
البحث
الصرفه فهذا هذا القلق انا مش عارف ليش
رغم انه يعني في هناك قلق اكبر منه يتعلق
بالاي اي اي يعني الذكاء الاصطناعي لا يجب
ان نختزله بالك جي بي تي وانما هناك في
مسائل اخرى خطيره جدا من الممكن ان نتحدث
عنها ونلقي الضوء عليها في مشاريع خاصه
يعني مثلا مشروع دارب الامريكي هذا مشروع
وصل الى مرحله
التواصل الدماغ البشري مع الاهلي بشكل
مباشر هذه هذا الخطر للمفارقه مخترعه
ومؤسسه تشاد جي بي تي عم بتقول في تصريح
اخير يعني هذا كان امس ليل امس انه الذكاء
الاصطناعي يجب تنظيمه يعني حتى مؤسسه تشاد
جي بي تي يعني خايفه من فكره الذكاء
الاصطناعي الى هذا الحد بس اليوم انا راح
اسالك بحكم خبرتك ورؤيتك للموضوع هل هي
هذه المساله طفره وستزول وبالتالي سيعود
الانسان الى صانع هذه التقنيه الصانع
البشري لها
يعني ماذا بعد
لا لا طبعا اكيد الانسان لا يمكن
الاستغناء عن ادوات الانسان لا يمكن هذا
هذا قولا واحدا ونعم هذه طفره وسوف تمضي
لانه سوف ياتينا طفره اكبر منها وسوف
ياتين شيء اكبر منه يلهينا
[موسيقى]